is there is there a a common code a
fabric of DNA some sort of commonality
that you see with guys that do well as
entrepreneurs
yeah they they understand how to deal
with the large amount of chaos and
uncertainty I mean that that is it dude
that's you that's everybody that's every
entrepreneur when I go speak to
entrepreneurs early in my career I would
I would do this right especially the
software folks that I speak and like
nobody wanted to talk about it but I
knew it was just such a part of who they
were so I would ask everybody to close
their eyes and I'd say raise your hand
if you've gone through some kind of
adversity or chaos between the ages of 7
and 12. and ninety percent of the room
would raise their hands and I tell
everybody okay put your hands down open
your eyes
and I go you are my people like here's
what I know is because you went through
that that essentially qualifies you to
be somebody that can succeed in this
crazy world of of Entrepreneurship and
the reason why is because there is zero
certainty zero structures zero anything
you literally have to learn how to be
the person who can create this stuff and
guess what if you don't figure it out
you're gonna you're gonna stumble for
the rest of your life and if you figure
out a little bit you'll make a little
bit of money but if you don't do the
work you're gonna give it all back like
I've just you know there's levels to
this game but it's why those people even
I mean it's kind of a crazy proposition
Rich it's like
to believe that you can go create
something from nothing and be a thousand
percent accountable for your life most
people can't even be accountable for
anything they don't want that level of
responsibility they want to blame their
kids and their neighbor and their
government and the and all these people
around them for the way they are and
entrepreneurs say no I do not want to
give those people my power I'm going to
be 100 accountable for this and I'm
going to mold and create this and I
believe I don't know if it's just my
hallucination that they also know that
they need to work on themselves to
become the person who can create and
maintain it right like Jim Rohn said
this a long time ago he said uh you know
uh if somebody ever gave you a
millionaire you better hope that you
become a million or if somebody ever
gives you a million dollars you better
hope to become a millionaire really fast
because if not you're going to lose it
all right because having a million
dollars does not make you a millionaire
and you see this all the time with
professional athletes and people win the
lottery and it's just funny like some
people they say to me it's like my goal
is to be worth 100 million I go dude if
you were worth 100 million in the next
six months you would just lose it all
because you have not become the person
who can like the the financial
complexity of that right like people
don't get it they think I want this life
it's like you couldn't handle that life
you can't even handle a ten dollar
overage on your cell phone bill and you
think you can handle that you you've got
some work to do and that's that's the
part that I find fascinating is that I
think entrepreneurship is the best place
to attract that kind of person and
create the space for them if they're
willing to use that friction to grow to
to be a feedback loop for that
I get people that ask me often what do
you think you know important skills are
to have to be successful as an
entrepreneur and I've always gone back
to being a really really good Problem
Solver you have to be able to solve
problems
what is it for you
resourcefulness creative I I just I have
I have zero
um
zero connection with people that say
like I need money to make money or I
need this to do this or I need that it's
like no you need to go figure out how to
be resourceful right and you call them
problems I like the word puzzle I think
puzzle is a cool word if you can get rid
of your word problem and replace it with
a puzzle your life will be dramatically
better if you just think about like hey
I'm dealing with this person and they
created a real puzzle in my life then
people around you're like hey I like
Puzzles how do we solve this it's
fascinating how words really set frames
for forward motion or activity or action
so to me I think being resourceful is
the underlying
um skill that allows people to solve
puzzles right and resourceful is fun
because it's saying with the constraint
of not having all of the resources in
the world I need to be creative right
and this is why like sometimes you know
so I buy companies and I have CEOs who
report to me and I always pull the extra
cash out of the business and they and I
remember one CEO I had is like why do
you do that it makes it really hard for
me to grow the business I go because if
I left it there you would spend it and
no innovation is going to come from it
if you have an abundance of cash okay
your Innovation your creativity your
resourcefulness is a muscle and it will
only be developed if I put you in a
position where you have to create with
less resources than you think you have
and that is true for you and it's true
for your whole team so I'm actually
doing you a service by not giving you
that Capital to redeploy now if you can
present me with an opportunity that
makes sense and argue for it you have
unlimited funds you literally consider a
line of credit that's unlimited to do
whatever you want but most people and
this is true for personal or business
investment they don't have that rigor of
resourcefulness of saying okay what what
is the constraint so so to me it's the
question right it's like how do I get
this outcome without this resource right
how do I go buy a building without any
money how do I uh build how do I hire an
employee without any money so like
people like I need somebody to help me
buy back my time it's like great ask the
question how what's the puzzle the
puzzle is how do I get an employee
without spending any money okay well
that's called an intern oh I didn't
think of that I know you didn't think of
that because you had already set the
constraint as I need money to bring
somebody into my life to buy back my
time and it's just not true right so
it's it's that kind of stuff I think I
think people that
just decide to say like I'm not going to
use things for as an excuse and I'm just
going to try to and I I don't know man
for me personally I find it fun like
being resourceful being creative saying
I don't have all the resources when I
built clarity.fm I know you were on
there and many other people like Google
announced their competitors called help
out and all my investors sent me an
email like hey Dan did you see this what
are you gonna do with that Etc and I was
like I actually think Google's like okay
yeah they have searched they have
billions of dollars they have the
smartest people in the world but they're
at a disadvantage because they have all
the stuff and because they have all this
stuff they don't have any clear
Direction they have no constraints that
they have to observe and I know exactly
what's happening in this company is
they've got about a ton of people
working on a bunch of different things
and because there's a bunch of different
stuff they're distracted they have no
they have no Focus so I actually reached
out to the product manager that was
working on this product I went down to
the Googleplex and had lunch with them
and dude as soon as I sat down I looked
them in the eyes I was like there's no
there's zero issues for a few reasons
one they were doing a bunch of stuff
that I'd already tested I know it's not
going to work so let them go figure that
on their own and two when I looked this
guy in the eye I could tell he was not
gonna die to solve this problem now that
might sound intense for people I don't
give a dude I was willing to
personally sacrifice everything I had in
my life to solve the problem of
connecting entrepreneurs with other
entrepreneurs that move their dreams
forward period full stop I would fight
for that result and I knew for a fact
that that pm at Google who's one of
thousand was not gonna fight for Google
he did not care about the problem to the
level I cared about and to me when I
because I've invested in hundreds of
companies the entrepreneur who cares
about the problem that falls in love
with the problem will be resourceful
enough to come up with the right
solution to solve the problem and that's
that to me is why it was important for
me to look at him in the eye and see
does he have it inside of him no Kate's
team let's get back to work don't worry
investors were good team stay focused I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out